[Musique]
c'est
ou santé actuellement
c'est un soulagement
il fallait que j'aille rendre le code
mon enfant est essentielle de tout les
plus importants steredenn
le présent la république et le plongeon
extrême très sensible tout ce qui s'est
passé on nous a instruits à l'effet de
prendre toutes les dispositions
conformément aux souhaits de la famille
de donc l'enfant soit rapatrié élus mais
ici dans son village
[Musique]
prince est un enfant aimé né dans les
faubourgs d'abidjan comme dans un conte
des frères grimm prince rêve d'un
ailleurs qui peut lui en vouloir
[Musique]
et
ils g dans le train d'atterrissage d'un
avion d'air france et meurt dans le ciel
à 14 ans tué par le froid et le manque
d'oxygène
son corps est retrouvé à l'arrivée à
paris
prince courait après un mirage mirage de
l'occident paris la tour eiffel
mourir à 14 ans en voulant s'arracher à
son pays n'est pas un fait divers
ici en afrique et ailleurs en occident
qui porte le poids de sa mort en rendant
hommage à laurent barthélémy annie
guibaï dit prince
on voulait comprendre comprendre depuis
l'afrique
ce mirage d'europe qui tue chaque jour
sur les routes de la migration serait
mortelle de millions d'africains
je voudrais vous annoncer à tous pour
officiellement une corde et annick by
and design laurent battles amy est
arrivé en côte d'ivoire je voudrais que
chacun de vous continuer appuyez vous ne
le pourrez son âme
chacun de nous continue a adressé des
prières ou que nos fils notre camarade
pu se reposer en paix mais ça aussi
l'occasion pour moi de revenir encore ce
qui s'est passé n'est pas a reconduit
aujourd'hui
vous avez l'impression que si vous ne
quittez pas ici vous ne pouvez pas
réussi si vous ne prenez pas l'avion
n'est pour paris si je vous le répète à
chaque fois beaucoup d'entre nous ont
fait les études ici ils ont réussi ici
si vous fournissez des efforts il ya des
moyens légaux
il ya des bouchons vous n'aurez même pas
à dépenser 5 francs pour prendre l'avion
c'est vous on va vous donner tout ce que
vous voulez mais il faut travailler il
faut fourni des efforts
[Musique]
oui
et
voilà sinon moi j'avais j'aime beaucoup
l'art à la fin je suis prêt à tout
affronter même cette même si cette mère
ma vie en jeu je suis pas moi moi je
suis prêt à prendre je m'en bats les
joies les fait sortir ma famille de la
misère parce que là bas
maya il ya beaucoup d'argent mais si un
enfant quand nous voyons bien les films
à la télé des troubles a dit c'est tout
cette décoration russe est une série
très mal français très magnifique
nous aussi nous arriver et nous étions
là en un pays où on reçoit tout le monde
qu'on parle pas de papiers ont pas dit
cela mais à voir la base sans papiers on
parle de sud dont tu vois la bête
prestique donc mûri depuis la biomasse
de la rai a beaucoup de louis aragon
c'est la vie la vie insécurité vu la
série
moi je ne peux pas passer par là mais ne
soit laissé aux soins du ministre de la
grèce mais aussi pour moi je vends ma
tablette qui peut mata très mauvais
d'antan
[Musique]
ce les avis de richesses nous avons
recommandé aux parents dès que tu pas
prévenu nous donner l'information
pour moi c'est inimaginable on savait
que sur les réseaux sociaux ça disait
qui a un enfant qui est parti qui a été
retrouvé mort à la suite d'un voyage et
cela je peux pas m'imaginer que c'est un
de mes élèves je pouvais pas imaginer
je le connais comme l'élève
qui est timide ce que
et comme on a fermé sur lui-même il
n'est pas bouillon et s'est pas fait
remarquer on peut pas lier cela à la
psychologie il faut plutôt voir dans le
sens de l'environnement des influences
que les enfants subissent dans le milieu
où il vous dit tout il évolue je ne lis
même pas ça à l'autorité familiale à
l'environnement familial mais plutôt à
l'environnement extrafamilial et
extrascolaires
[Musique]
c'est dommage mais ma saison
c'est une citation qui m'a beaucoup
perturbé ça m'a beaucoup pas tomber
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
[Musique]
enfin
voilà
il a battu lundi
le mahdi les autorités aéroportuaires me
dit que l'enfant a été aperçu dans le
voisinage de l'aéroport dans la
broussaille le mardi de lundi à mardi
avait dit à minuit
et c'est la nuit de mardi dès 22h dans
avec des trois heures que l'avion devait
décoller de la france assurait qu'ils
étaient cachés si c'est le miracle y
revenir s'agrippe léotard d'atterrissage
[Musique]
il peut être constaté de dégâts c'est à
dire à moi il a dit plus haut ce coup ci
il n'a pas dit où les boissons peut pas
n'a pas dû au hasard mais n'a pas de
base
le corps de prince et transporté à
l'intérieur du pays
à quatre heures de route d'abidjan
[Musique]
l'adolescent va reposer dans le village
familial de logobia un village de
brousse
loin de l'agitation de la capitale
[Musique]
tu
ben
[Musique]
on me dit il a marché on entend km on
s'est retrouvés à l'aéroport il ya
problème
tadic est quelqu'un sait qu'il a marché
quelques lacets cette base cela nous
disent qu'il est qu'elle était avec lui
à machin ou qu'il commençait ce qui
s'est passé là-bas nous le disons
clairement nous on ne peut pas penser on
ne peut même pas imaginer que ce travail
pour les faits sont caractérisés ben ali
qui sont arrêtés senna photo cl
obéissant pour lui il n'est pas violent
n'est pas carré on n'a jamais dit ainsi
le 5 octobre relate en avant il a
insulté tel cas se nourrir il s'est bâti
est ici notamment et c'est un affront
qui voulaient fait sortis séparément
correct et à ne pas nier le fait que
nous étions et nous sommes pour la revue
les présents dans laquelle nous vivons à
la maison comme bienvenue chez nous à la
maison des montets d'abord fui le procès
censé parler consommer du budget modeste
je suis désolé c'est le conseil vis
duquel sont pauvres et lui qui la rend
donc mère à l'âge de 14 ans la veille
déjà le souci du bluff a sorti ses
palais ses frais de la politique des
paiements trans qui séparera puissent
vivre comme les yeux bressols pas comme
des personnes au monde n'ont pas la
chance je suis bien supporté
[Musique]
oui
un gosse de 14 ans meurt l'émotion
parcourt la planète
et puis elle retombe aussi vite
les fai mettent pourtant tragiquement en
cause la sécurité de l'aéroport
mais l enquête piétine avant d'être
bientôt enterrée comme tant d'autres
pas de responsable pas de démission
le long du mur que prince a sans doute
escalader les autorités font raser tout
un bidonville en prétendant dégager un
dérisoire périmètre de sécurité
où allons nous
m
abaissez la pâte
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les modèles
[Musique]
je ne peux pas connaître les raisons
puis un cadre d'un tel agissement
pendant qu'un problème se situe à un
point donné un point précis pourquoi ne
pas résoudre le problème à ce niveau-là
plus d'aller pourquoi incriminer lacombe
le révérend qui sont en bordure ou bien
à proximité de l'aéroport
qu'est ce qu'ils ont fait pourquoi est
ce que savait qu'ils sont responsables
de cette situation
[Musique]
oui je moi les jours se suivent et se
ressemblent
comme beaucoup de jeunes africaines il
vient pressent que mon avenir se pose
derrière moi encore notre jour lieu
aujourd'hui j'ai fait mon frère ma
décision est prise
quito le monde à la mer que la honte
devant ma mère
une aide qui tous ces années c'est signé
pour un fils aujourd'hui à fait
incapable pour rien dans le quartier
[Applaudissements]
nous sommes calmes et nous dise dans un
éclat de rire
les ivoiriens qui comme prince songa
mais c'est à dire littéralement obsédé à
l'idée de partir de gagner l'europe
comment prince est il devenu gammées
dans le cybercafé de son quartier
c'est bien possible il y passait
beaucoup de temps 10 est proche
avec des gens à des projets des plans de
fond celle de british le fait de poser
avec eux et puis tu vois c'est une chose
la voirie sont prévus
ils ont très jolie des gens d'ici rev a
avalé les cybers pouvoir avoir un
objectif la barre
tous les enfants ils ont des smartphones
ils ont des comptes facebook
ils ont ceci il en a compté voir ça ils
communiquent et la communication est
intense
ces échecs de ventre et ça ça échappe à
tout contrôle
vous avez vos lèvres dans l'éducation
que vous voulez mais quand il saute et
qu'ils sont dans la rue avec d'autres
personnes qui leur disent le contraire
de ce que vous disent les vitrines -
commencé c'est compliqué
vous pouvez pas dit que je peux être
avec 424 intérêts mon fils à moi quand
il s'est lui dit qu'il va à l'école
entre l'icône plus la maison
[Musique]
[Musique]
j'étale à laventie ça n'a pas marché
je suis un migrant déchets mais j'ai
vécu des situations tragiques
donc je vais transmettre ce message là à
toute la jeunesse qui veut laisser
d'adressé risque en euros
[Musique]
où
mais gêné par compris en fait comment ça
va se passer je n'ai pas pris de
renseignements allez c'est parti comme
ça et c'est clairement le monial et
était de rester en tunisie suivre une
formation en médecine comme ça n'a pas
marché je me suis retrouvé en libye ils
vont très bien dormi en prison
on a été vraiment mal traités
naturellement on a vécu quatre mois de
souffrance chaque jour est différent ni
frappent d'autres hubert devient fou je
me suis pas lavés et j'ai des projets
qui est un petit morceau de pain pages
où la mongeta devenir une personne moi
j'ai dit écrit ça fini pour moi
[Musique]
où
si quelqu'un pas mieux vaut s'ils votent
ils les libyens qui avot responsables it
is si la personne et tu la personne
n'est plus dans les gènes dans le désert
sans même l'intérêt c'est comme ça
chaque jour que dieu fait on suit avec
un chapeau que dieu fait on tue avec un
prince at il croisé la route d'un
passeur ou d'un marchand de rêves comme
le pense très fort son père et ses
frères
mais alors pourquoi le faire monter dans
un train d'atterrissage prince avait les
poches vides
le monde des passeurs est d'abord un
monde d'argent adams dosso le sait bien
dans son quartier populaire d'abobo il
connaît parfaitement ce monde complexe
des petits passeurs qui débute dans le
quartier et se poursuit jusqu'en libye
ce monde parallèle adams l'a fréquenté
de l'intérieur
si tu es candidats au départ si tu es
d'accord l'a moins été mis en contact
avec un monsieur qui va titre pâtit
c'est de sensibiliser jeunes dans le
quartier il faut les traquer ils ont
deux appels des profils sur les réseaux
sociaux où ils font la publicité d
europe ils font la publicité des pays
maghrébins
une fois que j'ai pas en contact avec
eux on donne un point de rendez-vous à
bord ils ont un point de rendez-vous
dans presque chaque commune d'habitants
qui ont dépassé un amant le passé qui a
bobo est en contact avec celui d'iam ans
il est encore temps qu'avec celui de
yopougon les en contact avec la série
des trois villes merci tout de suite que
c'est là-bas en cause notre lieu de
conversations ça depuis des changes
lui il se promène imputé à l'état fin
dans un bien comme ça vous ne connaissez
pas et vient vous salir et fait sa
rentrée des voix de loin et v votre thé
ou d'un café
et puis il envoie son sujet il va avoir
maintenu à 3 personnes vont s'intéresser
à son sujet et à partir de là est en
contact avec des personnes exécutées
parmi sept personnes qui sont en train
de faire le café
nous allons maintenir la personne qui
vont s'intéresser à son sujet
[Musique]
six candidats au départ si tu jettes à
colas - été mis en contact avec ce qui
va être pratique
[Musique]
m
moi je fais la liste ainsi jamais
j'entends parler de ça les fait la liste
elle tu reviens d'une longue enquête
auprès de la presqu île ce qu'ils
veulent c'est parti comment ça se passe
j'ai moi-même disons que le cameroun au
maire de sète
il ya des gens là bas ils envoyaient des
vidéos et ça ils défendent de
l'artificiel en balade idéologique voilà
moi je suis bien ici et c'est un espagne
sommet puis ouais ils le feraient rêver
vandal qui m'aident à la main d'être des
passeurs les espaces web
le programme cela vous attendez parlait
souvent des gens qui voyagent sur l'eau
d'accord est ce que j'attendais parler
que c'est parce qu'on avait souvent dans
l'eau alors qu'ils attendaient ça
mais vu 7 pouces association là est ce
que au bout de ses idées le candidat
annoncé patino
[Musique]
voilà ne risquez pas de votre vie c'est
pas bon de voyage aussi l'eau c'est pas
bon quand tu pas une fois que tu veux
dans l'eau c'est fini tu vas pouvoir te
balance il a pulvérisé ce que tu voulais
réaliser
voilà encore à sensibiliser aussi vos
amis vos camarades
voilà ce n'est pas en peinture voilà qui
fait tousser schéma bizarre à sa pa bon
soit en bus dans le désert sans tomber
dans l'eau car une fois deux semaines en
outre fini
voir des amis ouais voilà dans ça comme
ça donc vous voyez vos amis vous les
interrogez vous le demande et si demain
ils veulent voyager
si vous voyagez dit l'être n'allez pas
en tunisie
n'allez pas en déduit là bas on tue on
tue les gens des autres c'est un
dépliant que nous avons effectués qui
traite de l'histoire d'un jeune homme
qui a passé près de trois ans de sa vie
à économiser pour le début lyon français
pas ce qui peu près de 3000 euros et un
beau matin il décide d'aller voir son
ami pour les dix que lui valent en
europe wall et un ticket mais se
cherchent et se chercher dans le langage
ivoiriens c'est un peu aller trouver un
mieux-être trouver
des revenus beaucoup plus conséquent
pour voir aussi un pouvoir d'achat
beaucoup plus élevé donc il décide
d'aller en europe
françois recevoir ensemble oui oui oui
bonsoir j'ai tous les droits
[Musique]
cet après midi on va projeter des films
le premier team va montrer la vie réelle
de vos enfants en europe
je vais parler un français qui aura su
comprendre le français les quads voir
vos enfants quand ils passent par le
désert et pluvieux labellise arrive en
europe là quand ils arrivent là les
blancs l'aller mais dans les salles
c'est une salle comme ça avec plusieurs
lits et il a donné à manger y-dom bien
ça faut parler à toulalan
il marche bien il donne bien après les
blogs de l'avocat pour faire papier pour
avoir leurs papiers pour travailler là
bas mais il passe deux ans trois impôts
tribunal au pas les papiers
quand c'est comme ça il peut plus voir
revenir
il veut plus voir rester là bas mais
ceux qui vous disent pas et vous dit pas
tout ça quand vous les appelez à maman
ça va ici au moment je vis bien à main
ici pour avoir envoyé un peu d'argent
mais comme nos collègues omg la baronne
dire ou pas voilà ils économisent viejos
apprécierez vous avoir sa prétendue
montérégie en europe c'est votre pays on
va vous montrer la vraie réalité
vendre ici ou se vendre là bas manger
son bon gabarit cissé au lieu de
fouiller dans plus belle la ba vivre ici
mourir là-bas
le deuxième film c'est deux ans de vos
enfants qui ont réussi à arriver là bas
mais qui voit la protée l'aï soit
romains ont traversé le désert la mer
pour arriver ils vont montrer la vie
réelle ce qu'ils ont traversé quoi
bouleurs tu cotises pendant cinq ans
vous allez rouler dans la mer est ce que
c'est bon ça il ya au moins celle de nos
proches qui a plus là où d'autres sont
restés dans la baisse au moment de son
arrivée mais vous raconte pas la vérité
[Musique]
à
aujourd'hui la nous montrer l'art et mat
on est partis en libye on était tous là
bas il ya plein qui sombre dans l'eau
une fois tu dis à quelqu'un d'à est
vraiment moi j'étais en ville à
sincèrement ça va pas en afrique - suis
d'accord avec ça mais aller se faire
aller se fait souffrir à aller se faire
bastonner par deux africains encore à
qui qui c'est qui fait reconnaître n'est
pas africain la le mans mais mon fils
aîné me je vais pas lui dit d'emprunter
la voie de la mauritanie et a su passer
moi j'ai été plusieurs fois sur l'eau
mais il ya des gens que moi j'ai vu
mourir c'est pas la peine on est en
prison là qu'on est en prison un débile
on a perdu en libye laffey atheridge
adoption de le fou quand il est interdit
frappé là et à une femme enceinte la
cape du quai mort sur le champ elle n'a
pas supporté de la messe d'enterrement
m'a traité ses propres frais cameroun et
il va dire de tous les jours bien là et
puis ils l'ont pas enterré pour
commencer c'est dangereux il entend
diriger ce qu'il a dit c'est réel parce
que moi dans le second était dans la
même prison
on a crû de 4,8 et mata n'allait pas
revenir à rennes mais je suis parti en
guinée de la guinée sur une au mali mais
les cheveux non conduire au munster
ce que nous disons à l'union européenne
justement ce que nos demandes
au gouvernement on ne voit rien à nos
pas nous aider surtout ils n'ont qu'à
nous installer ils n'ont qu'à chercher
des moyens pour nous du parti d'avoir
voilà une fois qu'on l'installé qu'on
arrive à manger on arrive à fait de quoi
attirer à faible ou la famille dollars
mais celle ci est d'aller en europe là
il pourrait prendre la voie normale
il sait qu'un joaillier me trouvais en
france et je vais pas mettre l'enfant
dia parti pour les béni donc vraiment
moi je voudrais que tous fassent la même
phase on voit ton voir la vidéo on voit
mesure ne va pas tarder à voile et vie
de voir les badauds ginoux comment ça se
passe on voit tout mais comment fait si
ça va pas ça va pas vous abonner
il est la voix parlée alors céder reebok
d'être lesquelles on n'a plus gagné pour
la vie
bon
oh
[Musique]
zep et sa scène c'est quoi c'est le
déluge tout mouillé à c'est le déluge de
son amie laure manaudou
ah oui samedi c'est la dernière soirée
ok
donc je serai pas au milieu j'irai juste
à côté pour la musique voilà parce que
comme on n'a pas de câble pour tirer
jusque là bas lui les pratiquement
décharger
quand j'étais petit notre encours
rendait souvent visite l'était toujours
bien à bien s'intégrer bronze on nous a
dit qu'ils venaient là bas c'est lui qui
prenait en charge financièrement toute
la famille 10 m la vie il fait quand
fois là bas et nous faudra pour cela la
pomme blanche s'est la mieux adaptée qui
quoique une femme blanche ça sera match
dans leurs mains l aide d or noir attend
donc pour toi une fois là bas une femme
blanche venue que tuer et se donner at
war comme sens oui oui je m'attends ça
pourquoi ils partent
je pense que c'est dans ces à la
richesse de cette réponse la chaire de
ses réponses la basket sont multiples
que vous devez vous inscrire donc dans
le jeu pensé beaucoup à ça en général
celui qui est là bas il durera pas ce
qu'il fait comme métier tout ça là mais
il va te montrer que voilà il est bien
habillé la tempête le dimanche se met
devant les magasins et les photos et
quand le gars y voit qu'il va monter à
tout petit oui voilà mon ami intel ça
fait quoi si moi un an qu'il est
qu'ils en france ou qu'ils gagnent
italie mais ça va on s'en sort bien on a
déjà la mine la bonne mine
il est bien que je fis la misère morale
la misère morale là bas joli je pourrais
dire ce que je veux comme je veux
attends c'est fou ça seulement que tu
vas là-bas mais pourquoi qui ne va pas
dans une de nos forêts poussines 2 le
matin sa crise tu pour accueillir tant
que tu veux personne ne te dérange et
s'écoute
il n'y a pas de démocratie chez nous et
ça tu pourras t'en de l'enlever de la
tête
c'est vrai qu'il y en a qui meurt en
suis la mère et tout ça mais un certain
qu'ils passent donc qu'est ce qu'ils
peuvent que moi c'est peut-être dû de
ceux qui passeront alors qu'ici il n'ya
plus d'espoir et régis n'ont plus
d'espoir il ya plus de rêves ans et qui
sont déjà morts physique j'ai pas dit
john pas physiquement en termes d'
espoir de signer ce plan sont morts en
pétition en gros c'est vraiment nous on
n'essaie pas d'être moralisateur aussi
pas mais on se dit qu'à un moment aussi
il faut prendre en fait ce problème là
comme un tout et ne pas s'attaquer aux
conséquences ou mettre beaucoup d'argent
à faire revenir ceux qui sont partis
mais comment est-ce qu'avec cet agent
que des conditions à fait d'un
épanouissement locales ici
on
oh
un épanouissement locale oui c'est tout
simplement est cruellement ce qui
manquait à prince
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à 14 ans il pensait n'avoir plus
d'avenir
sinon celui de se projeter en europe
pour devenir footballeur ou scientifique
rêves illusoires horizon barrés de toute
une jeunesse dans l'un des pays pourtant
les plus prospères de l'afrique de
l'ouest et prospère pour qui
[Musique]
c'est à bâlois au centre du pays à cinq
heures de route d'abidjan que des
milliers d'ivoiriens achète le rêve
empoisonné le même que celui de prince
partir à l'étranger et devenir riche
pour 500 ou 600 euros ils prennent la
route pour la libye
la loi est depuis des années un point de
départ vers le sahara une plaque
tournante de la migration irrégulière
la chaîne a fini des passeurs y est bien
implantée depuis des années et puis la
pauvreté les richesses de la région là
comme ailleurs ils sont mal partagée
un d'alois personne n'échappe à cette
pieuvre de la migration irrégulière
toutes les familles sont touchées de
près ou de loin comme prince
la jeune home ou sakho a fantasmé
l'occident comme prince
elle est partie pleine de rêves et
d'inconscience wade dès cette année je
vais aller en italie
et cette fois-ci l'attenté et m'aider
dans ma tête
voyons voir étalés sur les mots vous me
violer ou vous mettre hiver l'entrée en
italie cet homme au suicide
mes parents étaient pauvres
quand on travaille avec mon père et je
me compte dans les pa ris pour manger
puis sont venus couper au courant de moi
je voulais aller pour aider me parle
je
[Musique]
je suis le père de mme sako
donc je voudrais fait des petits
éclaircissements d'abord qu'on ne
descendez pas vraiment ça n'a pas été
facile quand on s'est retrouvé au niger
il a fallu que je fais marcher mes
relations à bamako pour pouvoir la
soustrait de groupe
c'est ce que j'ai fait j'ai contacté mon
ami a beaucoup et lui il allait je les
envoyais ya vingt dix moutons
et ce qui m'a fait satisfaction elle n'a
pas été touché par les violets dieu
merci grâce à dieu elle a été protégée
padoue des fois monsieur l'exposé à une
vieille collectif tout temps ce conseil
sont victimes
ma première pièce et qui n 2 tons pâles
dans la mer des violets dia usa c'est ma
prière
[Musique]
élève le portel acheminait les venelles
à trouver un mari
donc c'est une chance pour elle pour ne
pas qu'on se moque d'elle on a fait son
mariage pendant que les gens vis s'est
moqué d'elle elle était bien dans le
mariage on a fait la fête de mariage
tous les gens n'ont pas eu le temps de
se moquer d'elle puisque ces mêmes qui
sont restés ici sont pas encore mariés
et elle avait un argument maman ils sont
venus pour démarrer et vous louez votre
mari sa voix
[Musique]
ou moins bien trouver un mari mais elle
sait que le regard des voisins est
souvent dur très dur pour les migrants
qui échouent dans leur voyage ou les
considère comme des perdants ou pire
comme des maudits
[Musique]
heureusement ou moins avait une idée
pour rebondir
on a commencé avec tous les deux mois
après on a arrangé deuxième cham 3ieme
ça on a fait ce salon des grands salons
des ventes là offrir le contrat doit
commencer à voir le grossiste qui vient
de france en descend souvent 300 même
comme ça l'est elle est capable je
confiance elles si elles ayant
financement est plus fait travailler au
moins cinq à dix jours elle peut même
fait d'autres fermes pour mettre des
jeunes dida pour le moment y'a pas un de
mes enfants qui pensent encore à leur
niveau
mais si jamais les moyens ne manquent
pour les attendre et qu'est ce que ça va
devenir si je n'arrive pas à les
encadrer
même actuellement nos voisins aient des
enfants sont parties d'un corps son
argent dans la semaine il a volé
l'argent de son papa chéri tu n'étais
pas arrivé en libye
sa voix une semaine maintenant
[Musique]
ce
beaucoup des jeunes
en l'avenir sans problème
toujours
m
cela
mais
[Musique]
c'est signé
non
un beau n'être pas
[Musique]
et
ans
réussir ici en côte d'ivoire facile à
dire
marc aristote et grasse et trois frères
et soeurs de prince aimerait bien y
croire et pour eux qui démarre dans la
vie professionnelle leur diplôme valent
moins que les passe-droits des fils et
filles de bonne famille
[Applaudissements]
je
ce qui se passe ça ne date pas de
maintenant s'attarder depuis l'
esclavage loin là-bas depuis la
colonisation et c'est qu'on apprend à
l'école tout ça ça nous met des choses
dans la tête que nous sommes dans un
furieux donc n'avons que ce complexe
d'infériorité là donc il faut changer
carrément la mentalité de la halle et
noir faut changer notre mentalité
il faut arrêter démontré que nos pays
sont excuse moi ça fait de la pointe il
qui sont des pays des gains des mises et
c'est là c'est vrai elle a misé pas tout
est aujourd'hui attendu de la mise et ya
des choses qui se font
et ces choses qui se font là il faut les
mettre en exergue pour que les élèves et
les enfants ne puissent comprendre que
il a dû bonheur ici je le dis mon temps
mais sensibilisation se sont pas déçus
ce qu'est un sou gêne ce qui fait peur
mais ça n'a pas marché
on a monté les consulats mère nature le
consul au on a montré le cadam on a
montré tous les atrocités humaines la
bande d'hommes mais les jeunes
continuent de partie il faut changer
leur fusil le pôle outre cela
télécommunications
nous on a choisi de s'axer sur tout ce
qui a valeur de valoriser ce que
l'accord doit de hbo a de bien propre à
la jeunesse l'éducation
le pays a besoin de vous
n'empêche beaucoup d'ivoiriens éprouve
un sentiment d'injustice face à une
europe qui monte ses murs toujours plus
haut
une europe qui se barricadent comme une
citadelle
le pays a besoin de vous mais dans quel
état et notre pays
à beaujeu aussi de répondre le père de
prince dans nos pays africains il ya le
népotisme qui inquiète à l'étagé
la corruption qui est âgée
le fossé entre les riches et les pauvres
qui fait que certaines personnes se
sentent offusqués
[Musique]
on
pour
ne partez pas réussi c'est ici martel
les enseignants les ong et tous les gens
raisonnables mais ce message à la
jeunesse se fracasse sur la réalité
d'une côte d'ivoire violente et depuis
vingt ans par les crises politiques il
se fracasse aussi face au creusement
monstrueux des inégalités
c'est vrai on essaie de dire aux jeunes
8 d'ici 50 ans la vni c'est la fri on
sent tous les chefs d'état se réunissent
depuis la vie est en afrique c'est ici
que demain les choses on se fait mais
dans l'est j'ai dit dans la réalité dans
le quotidien on apprend on voit pas
comme il a dit c'est même chef d'état
par exemple qui soigne par exemple à une
fracture qui vont là soyez en france
je prends un exemple qui sont venus gens
qui sont responsables de tout ce qui est
le système d'enseignement d'éducation
mais qui n'ont aucun gossip six doigts
[Musique]
e
ça y est on a dit ça m'a choqué
thomas c'est annie et thomas
ça m'a choqué les mains
[Musique]
tout est lié
et ça m'a choqué
[Applaudissements]
mon ami et moi
grâce est maintenant en bts de
secrétariat elle aimait son petit frère
plus que tout elle n'a rien vu venir
elle aurait tenté mais lui dire que son
rêve était une impasse
[Musique]
pourquoi forcément aller de manière
je n'ai pas disons que je n'ai pas libre
en faisant ça a même aidé dans la bas
toujours obligé de te cacher ça sera pas
de se cacher quand tu sais
je dois tu n'étais pas obligé d'être
blanchi la liberté n'a pas de prix
je ne pouvais pas vivre pas mal comme ça
choix avec
les avis
il ya ce qu'on appelle la liberté ici
voilà une certaine liberté qu'on peut
décrire
voilà c'est vrai nos pays est ce qu'il
est
mais il ya l'amusement l'ambiance tout
ce vacarme y voyant une
[Musique]
je suis bien ici j'ai rêvé d'un look
anacarde est allé me rallie à long terme
mais j'aime tellement mon pays je pense
que j'aurai le mal du pays
[Musique]
moi
c'est donc oui je l adore comme
[Musique]
où
à 100 si tu te promènes boulevard de la
chapelle à paris
regarde bien cette fresque celle de
prince
l'adolescent qui voulaient voir la tour
eiffel
un jeune comme les nôtres qui s'est
écrasé sur les murs fortifiés de
l'europe
puisse son beau visage résonnait comme
un mémorial aux dizaines de milliers de
migrants morts à nos frontières
[Musique]
oh
pour
[Musique]
le bout
non
tout
[Musique]
m